llegaron a Nueva York después de 36
horas Viajando en un autobús pagado por
el estado de Texas son migrantes
irregulares y pisan por primera vez la
ciudad con esperanzas pues amo un
Venezuela Colombia Panamá Costa Rica
Nicaragua Honduras Guatemala México y
Texas tenemos bueno muchas muchos deseos
de trabajar de trabajar salir adelante
Iniciar una nueva vida una nueva vida
que el Gobernador tejano el republicano
greca Bot no quiere que vivan dentro de
su estado
desde abril el político ha pagado buses
para transportar más de 6.200 migrantes
a Washington la capital de Estados
Unidos y en el vecino estado de Arizona
su homólogo Dark dussy siguió su ejemplo
con mil personas más
es parte de una estrategia para
presionar al presidente joeyden y a los
alcaldes demócratas a quienes acusan de
flexibilizar sus políticas migratorias
sin responsabilizarse de atender a los
migrantes vaiden rechaza hacer su
trabajo así que Texas sigue dando pasos
sin precedentes para asegurar nuestra
frontera Nueva York que es el destino
ideal para estos migrantes pueden
recibir los servicios de los que el
alcalde Adams ha presumido tanto en su
ciudad santuario sin embargo la
bienvenida en estas ciudades no ha sido
tan cálida los servicios sociales están
desbordados y muchos de estos migrantes
terminan durmiendo en la calle o en
albergues
y mientras los migrantes solicitan asilo
y buscan trabajo un proceso que dura
meses y pone a prueba cualquier
Esperanza los republicanos y demócratas
las alcaldías las gobernaciones y el
Gobierno Federal se responsabilizan unos
a otros de este repunte de llegadas
desde octubre Estados Unidos ha detenido
a más de un millón 700 personas en la
frontera con México el récord desde 1960